léon e leo
[Musica]
però ragazzi vi siete mai chiesti che
cosa leonardo di caprio ha veramente
fatto per raggiungere l'oscar
avete idea del sacrificio perché oggi
siamo qui per dimostrare e quindi sono
aggiunti ragazzi probabilmente questo
video sono la vj ed oggi siamo super red
carpet rampe in realtà c'è un la nardò
di caprio e molto incazzato che è
successo a sei già partito ok l'offerta
e stai cannes
ciao sono leo e ho veramente bisogno di
vincere questo premio ok questo già lo
sapevo è un videogioco ragazzi tra il
protagonista e leonardo di caprio e devo
raggiungere l'oscar quindi poi
sperimenterete che cosa leonardo di
caprio approvato nel raggiungere questo
cazzo di oscar lescaut sporca miglior
tutto è impossibile space to jump
lasciano un po palazzo [ __ ] non ho
visto che l'obiettivo ragazzi a
raggiungere me l'avete consigliato per
niente tutti sto videogame non lo fa
solo lasciato nel dimenticatoio prova
beh c'è sempre tempo perfetto non ho
preso un cazzo cioè l'oscar è ancora lì
che va a che fare oddio che hai lo so ho
perso il flusso regime ha schiacciato la
faccia bellissima devo andare na brutta
traiano e mio l'oscar dai cazzo l'hai
devi morire e ce l'ho fatta non fatica a
rega non ci arrivo è impossibile vai lì
mica tanto sto prendendo un sacco di
altri premi che sono praticamente
inutili excelent aggrega excellent una
minchia perché lo skal ancora non l'ho
preso a gehring car ma sono tutti figli
di caprio questi già fatta già fatta 500
di bonus
la prima dell'osso mi ha schiacciato
brutalmente non sono riuscito a
paparazzi né merda bellissimo quel
momento in cui ti fanno le foto e
dovrebbero pagare meno il cazzo i miei
chiaro che così difficile niente ora che
non ci riesco impulsività quanto sia
raggiungibile perché da fare per trovare
chi chiedevo trovare schiacciato a caso
ho capito di onorari steve jobs non
prenderà jos carlos tardo lady gaga in
co lady gaga perché c'è lady gaga che
cazzo vuol dire perché ce li chiamano
gaga ha sì stronza dai ma non è
possibile che a quanto mi stupì di
qualche a cagare
e un fenomeno core manco gli usa in
volta creevy qualcosa di figure fa vj e
bello caso scritto non hanno scritto
quello che lo giuro questo scriveva le
cose a caso non ho fatto neanche in
tempo a leggere perché devono esserci
paparazzo in mezzo ai [ __ ] dovete
togliervi che palle 2 combo voli pensi
tutti quanti
l'ho preso dai l'ho preso ma come
l'amore no ragazzi avevo preso stavolta
giuro [ __ ] eva ma come cazzo è
possibile lady gaga scrive prima c'è la
lady gaga a carissimo dai ma si dai dai
dai veloce madonna che nervi o ora che è
impossibile recita più forte quanto si è
impegnato a lei
oddio o non c'è anche matt damon con the
martian ma non puoi vincere tu non mi
sarei lady gaga incoming ma perché lady
gaga si faceva dedica poi rompe le palle
solo a me per carità di dio
niente da rompere i [ __ ] ma guarda
quello che ha superato l'oscar quell'ora
non l'ha neanche preso steve jobs non
l'ha neanche preso lo scapolo ha
superato non gliene fregava il cazzo ti
va bene
find the black trova il nominato nero al
nero ragazzi non lo trovo fan erano solo
gli articoli asso è non ne ho la piu
pallida vabbè vai perché c'è uno squalo
in mezzo vabbè ora ci ho fatta
sì l'ho preso son oscar ho vinto io sto
solo dio
cos'è lo sa ding credevo sfidare l'oscar
a devo lanciarli golden globe ma perché
c'è gaga ma perché devono metterci gaga
in mezzo non spedale che hanno capito io
devo fare ma non sa cos'è è un parà è
tifoso space invaders dello sparare
all'oscar ucciderlo fantastico dai sono
morto anno faccio quattro vita che culo
perché se gaga che cade dal soffitto
qual è il senso perché mi devo lanciare
i golden globe ricorda in globe di
capriano avrà un miliardo e mezzo come
mi mancava solo l'oscar dai zio mischia
tanto ci mette a morire come perché
l'oscar è un boss crepa gaga dammi la
mano canta qualcosa si deve morire male
lo sai vero ho vinto tanto stavo cadendo
nel vuoto da un ora e mezzo non so
perché
se mai è in transformers
ma la madonna questa è sta roba ma
veramente mica mi sembra uno di quei
boss di fondi metal slug del sud che
separavano i missili a casini già era
difficile prima guarda ci mancava solo
questo e vai vai prato di ragazzi sto
finendo i premi potrebbe essere un
problema questo ormai zio vai vai vai
vai vai vai spara spara leo conquistati
la vittoria
ho vinto ho vinto anche con la
evoluzione dell'oscar non son riusciti a
battermi vinto ce l'ho ce l'ho l'ho
preso l'ho preso vinto ce l'abbiamo
fatta ragazzi golden globes 0
amy 4 perché li ho lanciati tutti i
golden globe mi sono rimasti quattro
emmy 21 mtv movie awards è uno ha scarse
l'ho fatta ragazzi pressioni kate
continui c'è la premiazione a no non c'è
la premiazione proprio lui ha vinto e
boa finito che si dice sono un'incognita
là di tutto il video ma lady gaga che
cosa strana minchia c'entrava in tutto
questo è vero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi lasciato un bel live per leo che
vince lost ma seriamente io sto gioco
non lo capisco al st stati tutti i
testimoni che cosa ha dovuto subire leo
per vincere questo oscar il cazzo di
applausi comunque ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto cosa in tv è piaciuto al
suo argomento è un mi piace anche la
fascia di facebook è migliorata
l'estinzione lasciato mi piace pure per
leo che tassi chi cazzo sei frey e lo
può fare solo così deve vincerlo ancora
il telecomando a word per adesso faccio
io beh ragazzi